celebrations in the Salvadoran
Capital supporters of naive buele
cheering on a victory that will give the
controversial president a second
term before him we didn't have hope but
today we have it and that means a lot
appearing before a crowd of thousands
bukele called the election
historic now in the next 5 years just
wait and see what we're going to do
because we're going to continue doing
the impossible and showing the world the
example of El Salvador Naji bukele
largely owes his support to his
administration's Hardline policy to rid
the country of gangs like MS13 and the
18th Street gang which have caused chaos
in El Salvador for the last 30 years
though successful in dealing with
criminal gangs critics say the
suspension of civil liberties the
consolidation of power along with an
unconstitutional bid for reelection have
made bukele a democratically elect
elected dictator he has everything you
know all the power uh there are no
controls there's no independent of
powers so that's what we are seeing
today an
inconstitucional vadori and president
naib buuk would win by a landslide the
celebrations here in El Salvador's
historic Center are still massive
though human rights and civil liberties
Advocates continue to warn that El
Salvador is walking a dangerous tight
rope for a majority of Salvadorans the
promise of a future where Safety and
Security is the norm outweighs just
about any other alternative Manuel
rapalo Al jazer s
Salvador make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer